well when I left office we had an
agreement a peace agreement between
Israel and Egypt not a word of which has
been violated and we have an agreement
from the Israelis to withdraw from their
occupied territories in the West Bank
and also later the idea was within the
withdrawal from Syria and also from
Lebanon unfortunately in the last 25
years no progress has been made on those
issues that depend upon issues with
willingness to withdraw from occupied
territories and I don't think peace is
possible in this that comes of course
the other aspect of that is to make sure
that Israelis know that if they do
withdraw from the West Bank from East
Jerusalem from Syria and from Lebanon
that their security in their integrity
as a nation will be preserved with a
safety so that's been the quandary in
which we have wallowed in a way for the
last 25 years in my hope is that we'll
make some progress in the near future